in this video we're going to tackle one
of the big topics arguably the biggest
topic in climate science global warming
and climate change now if you missed the
previous videos on the first law of
thermodynamics and radiation you can
check them out here and here but I'm
going to recap the relevant points later
on in the video as we come to them in
more than one way global warming is an
energy problem the first law of
thermodynamics states that energy cannot
be created or destroyed only change from
one form into another and that if the
amount of energy entering an object is
different from the amount of energy
leaving an object then that object's
temperature will change now the earth is
in thermodynamic equilibrium with the
Sun with the amount of energy that we
absorb from the Sun in the form of
radiation being equal tema of energy
that we firmly radiate out into space if
for some reason the amount of energy
that the earth radiated were to increase
then the resulting energy imbalance will
cause the earth to cool while if some
reason the earth were to start radiating
less energy into space the resulting
energy imbalance will cause the earth to
warm this second scenario is exactly
what we are seeing happening the earth
is warming due to an energy imbalance
the question isn't if that's happening
the observational evidence to quite a
scientific establishment is unequivocal
the question instead is why it's
happening and how fast okay so evidence
indicates the earth is warming due to
radiating less energy than it absorbs so
let's consider the possibilities of what
could be responsible one the Sun is
emitting more energy they used to and
say the earth is absorbing more energy
they used to it's well known that the
Sun varies in its power output but over
the past 400 years it's only varied by
0.2 percent so not enough to account for
the global warming that we observe to
the earth is now absorbing more of the
energy that the Sun is giving out now
the Earth's orbit isn't perfectly
circular
it has eccentricity ellipticity and it
processes around the Sun and these minor
variations in its orbit give rise to
so-called Milankovitch cycles these are
cycles which determine over 26,000 year
period how much energy the earth is
receiving at the surface and comparing
the amount of energy that the earth is
receiving at the surface to the global
average surface temperature we actually
see an antique correlation the more
energy to the earth receives at the
surface
global temperatures go down so this
isn't the culprit and even accounting
for changes in the how reflected the
earth is its albedo doesn't account for
the energy imbalance that we're seeing
three there is an additional source of
heating which is introducing more energy
into the earth system and depending on
who you talk to this could be
earthquakes volcanoes meteors and pretty
much anything in fact but the fact of
the matter is that there is no
correlation between the frequency of
these events and global average
temperatures the only possible link
would be an increase in volcanic
activity leading into more aerosols
being ejected into the atmosphere so
things like dust and sulfuric acid being
injected into the stratosphere but if
that were the case then we'd actually
see a cooling as a result of increased
activity and we haven't seen a coulis
we've seen a warming and there hasn't
been a statistically significant
increase in volcanic activity over the
past century anyway for the earth is now
emitting less radiation into space than
it used to and comparing the total
outgoing radiation at the top of the
atmosphere to the global average
temperature we finally see a
statistically significant correlation
this is a hugely hugely complex system
that we are talking about and so there's
not going to be one culprit but the main
culprit in global warming is this
decrease in outgoing radiation the
question now then is what's causing it
in the second video in this series we
talked about the fact that the Earth's
atmosphere is very good at absorbing
long wavelength or thermal radiation and
that each layer in the atmosphere
absorbs and then re-emits the thermal
radiation that's given off by this
surface with the signal getting weaker
and weaker the higher you go the
chemical that's mostly responsible for
this effect is carbon dioxide which due
to its molecular structure is very
efficient at absorbing long wavelength
radiation what this means is if you were
in space and wanted to guess the
temperature of Earth based on the amount
of radiation that it's giving out with
hotter objects giving out more thermal
radiation then you'd get a temperature
way lower than what we experienced here
at the surface and this is because as we
talked about in a very first video in
the series at least to begin with the
atmosphere gets cooler the higher you go
up as well as getting thinner and
eventually the atmosphere gets to a
point where it's so thin the thermal
radiation that's emit
just escapes off into space because
there aren't enough atmospheric atoms
above that point to get in the way and
absorb the radiation now we call the
temperature of that layer the effective
temperature and the height at which that
temperature occurs the effective
emission height for the earth the
effective temperature is about 252
Kelvin or minus 21 degrees Celsius which
is the equivalent of the earth emitting
all this thermal radiation from about
halfway up the troposphere so effective
emission height of between five and six
kilometers above the surface for the
earth to emit less radiation into space
then it would have to have a lower
effective temperature but what could
cause that enter carbon dioxide because
co2 absorbs thermal wavelengths of
radiation
it's what prevents thermal radiation
emitted in the lower atmosphere from
escaping out into space it effectively
determines how transparent the
atmosphere is to thermal radiation the
more co2 you have in the atmosphere the
less transparent it is and so the higher
you have decline before thermal
radiation can escape off into space
increasing the effective emission height
and the troposphere gets cooler the
higher you go so increasing co2
concentrations in the atmosphere leads
to a greater effective emission height
and so a lower effective temperature so2
concentrations therefore effectively
determine how much energy the earth
radiates out into space and so
determines its temperature since the
Industrial Revolution we've been
increasing co2 concentrations in the
atmosphere faster than at any other time
in the Earth's history in 1750 before
the Industrial Revolution every million
molecules in the Earth's atmosphere
contained 280 molecules of co2 while
today in 2015 every million molecules in
the atmosphere contains 400 co2
molecules now that might not seem like a
hugely significant increase but compare
that to the past four hundred thousand
years of co2 concentrations in the
atmosphere we are influencing the planet
in ways that it has never been
influenced before co2 concentrations
have been much higher in the past but
they have never changed this quickly in
the past which means that the climate
has never changed this quickly
and life on Earth is utterly unprepared
for that now carbon dioxide is the
poster child of global warming it's the
molecule that everyone has heard of but
sometimes you hear of other molecules
like methane nitrous oxides water vapor
being referred to as greenhouse gases
and what this means simply is that these
molecules also absorb long wavelengths
thermal wavelengths of radiation and in
some cases do so much more effectively
than co2 the difference is though with
the exception of water vapor these
molecules have a much lower
concentration in the atmosphere than
carbon dioxide and so have less of a net
greenhouse effect than co2 water vapor
is actually the most significant
greenhouse gas of all contributing about
50% of the net greenhouse effect however
because it hasn't seen an exponential
increase in concentration since the
Industrial Revolution it tends to get
ignored when people talk about global
warming but it's worth noting that as
the planet warms the atmosphere will
actually be able to support more and
more water vapor so we can expect it to
play an even greater role in the
greenhouse effect in years to come co2
and to a lesser extent methane however
gets star billing when it comes to
global warming because humans have
through activities like energy
generation agriculture and transport
vastly increase their concentrations in
the atmosphere and so have directly
controlled and influenced global average
temperatures but by how much it's been
estimated that humans have warmed the
global climate by approximately not 0.8
degrees Celsius since the Year 1880
which is a reasonable benchmark for how
much we've all the climate since the
Industrial Revolution now that's the
warming to date warming in the future is
much more uncertain because we are
forcing a vastly complex system in ways
that we only have a reasonable grasp of
but the rub of it is that future changes
and future warming will not be good much
of the effect that we will have on the
climate in the future will come down to
how much carbon we put into the Earth's
atmosphere and the Intergovernmental
Panel on Climate Change or IPCC have
considered multiple scenarios of
emissions and
some cases mitigation by the world and
tried to determine what the effect will
be now even after a global scientific
effort we cannot say for certain how
much warming will occur for a given
amount of co2 in the atmosphere but we
can say within some error bars the 21st
century will see between naught point 3
and 1 point 7 degrees Celsius of
additional warming in the best-case
scenario where the world reduces
emissions as the century goes on and
extensively mitigates its carbon impact
in the worst case scenario where we
continue to emit as we currently are and
increases emissions every year we expect
the global average change in temperature
to be between two point six and four
point eight degrees Celsius that's a
global average some areas will see
significantly more warming even than
that the effects of this warming are
called climate change and encapsulate
melting ice caps rising sea levels
increases in extreme weather events and
massive population movements I asked my
supervisor here at the University of
Exeter what he expected the long-term
effects of climate change to be unless a
miracle occurs a thousand years from now
all the ecosystems we know today will be
destroyed there may be some residual
animals living in zoos to kept alive but
like across Africa all the savanna with
the elephants are gone eventually the
ice caps melt like Florida is a couple
little islands left all the plants and
animals are used to very slow change in
the environment and it would be a very
rapid change but overwrap it won't be so
rapid that within a given lifetime it
looks like a huge difference like from
the time you're born a time to die
oh maybe snowstorms are less frequent
than when you were a kid it won't be
that noticeable but you added up over
500 years or a thousand years and it's
catastrophic
well this is the big question if we
carry on as we currently are and do
nothing about climate change then the
end of civilization and biodiversity on
this planet as we know it could be on us
in centuries maybe sooner but we are
poised the unique moment in history we
have the opportunity to decide whether
we are going to take action decisive
action to mitigate the worst effects of
climate change for our descendants or do
nothing and what this opportunities sail
by
the fundamental thing that we need to do
is reduce the amount of carbon that is
in the atmosphere and the first thing to
do towards that goal is to reduce our
emissions to zero and then beyond and
start extracting carbon dioxide from the
atmosphere what that means to begin with
is moving from fossil fuels such as oil
coal and natural gas to more renewable
sources such as renewables like wind and
hydro and also nuclear and then
eventually on to other energy sources in
the future like fusion it means changing
agricultural practices from carbon
intensive methods like meat production
to a more vegetarian diet it means
increasing efficiency in technologies
from transport to home insulation but
most of the fate of the world's action
on climate change rests on the
conference of parties 21 that is
happening in Paris this December if
anything is going to make the slightest
dent in global warming it's gonna take
coordinated international action and the
time for that action well actually the
best time for that action was ten years
ago but the next best time is now we
covered a lot in this video so if you
made it this far well done in this video
we covered the Earth's energy balance
finding that the earth is warming
because of an energy imbalance we
examine the possibilities of that energy
imbalance and concluded that the earth
is radiating less energy out in space
than it used to we explained why carbon
dioxide is responsible for that decrease
in outgoing radiation being that it
reduces the effective temperature of the
earth we considered other greenhouse
gases like methane and water vapor
we looked at the warming to date due to
carbon dioxide and other greenhouse
gases and also considered future warming
being depend on how much carbon we put
into the atmosphere and lastly we
considered what we can do to try and
stop global warming next time we're
going to look at what many people think
of as a last resort plan of action
geoengineering deliberately changing the
Earth's climate now if you'd like to
swat up on the different ways in which
we can change the Earth's climate then
you should check out my friend feathers
a video series on the subject where he
considers all the options that are
available to us and in my video which is
going to be the last one in this crash
course we're going to look at the
physics of how we could do that thank
you for watching if you'd like to
support this series and you can do so
via its Kaunas page
Conner's is a free website that gives
you extra functionality when you're
trying to learn from an online course
and also gives you the opportunity to
donate to support the creators well me
and if you did like this video then
please do like it on YouTube and
consider subscribing to this channel for
more educational content okay so here's
my workbook it's important we're good
it's a book I like books and it's got
the work in that's my laptop which has
got the scripts with crash course videos
and that's my Japanese piece Lily always
important to keep that around because it
keeps our oxygenated